well you often hear politicians brag
about their public service it's such a
sacrifice
and yet nancy pelosi's career suggests
maybe you missed your calling
she spent three decades in congress and
yet somehow nancy pelosi
is worth tens of millions of dollars
how'd you get so rich
well her husband paul pelosi operates an
investment firm and he's made a lot of
remarkably well-timed trades over the
years he really should be on cnbc just
the other he made another one paul
pelosi snapped up between one and five
billion dollars worth of stock in nvidia
that's a semiconductor company now turns
out congress is preparing to vote on a
50 billion dollar subsidy to the
semiconductor industry hmm
charles gasparino is a senior
correspondent with fox business he joins
us to assess the story joy thanks so
much for coming on is there any way to
get paul pelosi's stock tips before he
does the trades
i i mean this dude is a rising star on
wall street uh dan loeb stevie cohen
they got something on this guy he almost
never misses uh you know it really is
remarkable you know here's the thing
tucker obviously this brings up the
notion of is this insider trading is she
giving him some tips we should point out
that you know the the sec and the doj
have brought cases on you know insider
tips in pillow via pillow talk trust me
on it's happened i don't believe this
hits the insider trading bar uh you know
a lot of this information about this
legislation was bouncing around there it
has to be material non-public stolen
disappropriated it kind of doesn't hit
those barriers but what this does hit is
limousine liberalism arrogance on
steroids i mean he knows that he has an
information edge not saying it's illegal
but he knows he has an information it's
he and his wife talk about stuff right
okay he knows what's coming down the
pike he's got sources and it's not
probably not just her uh i mean it's
really disgusting looking and you know
if you want to understand why people
distrust government it's because of
stuff like this that's right it's
exactly right it's not because it's not
because some dignitary went to the trump
hotel okay which i read tons of stories
about that when donald trump was
president i mean oh they're trying to
cozy favor you know cuddle up to the
donald trump administration because they
go to the trump uh hotel in washington
that's nothing okay this is the bad
stuff getting an edge knowing that it
just flies in the face of fairness again
i'm not saying this is illegal as a
matter of fact i don't think it's
illegal based on everything i know about
insider trading but it looks like crap
and it makes everyone cynical about
democracy it'd be very simple for
congress to ban any kind of trades like
this just put it in a blind trust but
they won't and it's and you know what
it's hypocrisy
and it's and for someone who lectures us
on the evils of capitalism like nancy
pelosi does all the time it's really
disgusting
amazing charlie espino great to see you
tonight thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight